in this challenge episode we'll try the
world's stickiest table tennis rubber
ping pong with the remote control car
and more let's get into it
come on ML that's too easy try this one
moving Target
welcome to this challenge episode we
asked you guys on Instagram what
challenges we can do with the remote
control car okay let's go monster truck
uh for a loop
[Music]
oh but we need to play with the wheel
next I actually think it's going to be a
very good spin here do you want Top Spin
or backspin you can choose
oh what is yes okay oh
ah how is the spin that good actually
backflip shot
[Music]
it got a shot on
Okay so we've built our own table tennis
robot from remote control cars I'm
pretty sure this won't go well
oh nice
it actually works all right we'll
release 10 and let's see how many you
can get okay full gas
it's going too fast
[Music]
you didn't get many shots though what is
the success I'm not sure normal table
tennis robot is better yeah it needs a
rest
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was nice nice slice good one oh
so are you ready
are you ready
should we start off with the the normal
Rubber and then try and see if we can
make an even spinny rubber yeah
it's like a dead fish this is really
that bad oh
it's the world's stickiest rubber that's
legal to play with let's glue it on and
a layer on the pong finish Sensei blade
and then we cut it let's take off the
protective layer the world's slowest
peel the intensity
okay the first bounce test one two three
let's see the stick test it's not even
sticky maybe you just need to push it a
bit harder
the honey bear once more honey these
challenge ideas come from our amazing
subscribers so make sure you hit
subscribe if you want to see your
comments in the next challenge episode
the smell is really interesting yeah
[Music]
spin on it
it's gonna get stickier the more it
tries okay drop it
huh yeah it's more absorbed no it's only
one bounce
okay now we have let's try a slow shot
first
[Music]
now you can just drop it it's coming oh
now it didn't stick it's it's sometimes
sticky sometimes not you try and play
with it
[Music]
yes
so slow it's like it's like five times
slower than your normal shot let's come
up with something new dried up handful
of Wax
very tasty sticks quite well
yeah I mean it's definitely an
improvement but you still can't put you
can't make spin with it next up glue oh
yeah yeah we need more
trained professionals but we don't know
what we're doing
that's like minus bounces let's try and
play with it
[Music]
[Applause]
um
spin give me your hardest book
oh it is it was so fast you couldn't see
it
[Music]
ball catch
whoa that was crazy that was way better
than shushin world's stickiest racket a
snowman if you want to do this on
pumpkin in the store and get these balls
all right Emil I think we're gonna
destroy these guys yeah definitely well
no chance
[Applause]
oh nice
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dude hi
[Music]
good one thanks Robin
[Applause]
[Music]
oh nice one not nice enough
[Music]
I don't know if there's anything why is
nobody serving sure yeah that's true
actually
that's why
[Music]
that was perfect
[Music]
there you go I can't reach
what do you mean you can't reach I
trusted him very nice
[Applause]
oh my goodness
[Music]
that's your side
[Music]
nice
okay that was good thank you
good
I'm just in case I have a Deja Vu but in
the right side now
good head one
[Music]
whoa wrong way okay we can try to hit
the cop
come on
I lose come on high five high five
try and catch me
Victory okay are we ready we are ready
yeah yeah I did
oh I'm going steady steady steady
[Music]
ah Emily you have a better roof than me
[Applause]
[Music]
the one who knocks the other one over
first wins
oh
give me the controller no not yet we
haven't been driving enough yeah we have
remember to hit subscribe and see you
next time I can't come up with anything